like there's some cool Comedians and I'm
not saying cuz all of them you know cuz
I said that in my book I all comedians
ain't [__] up but most of them are
some insecure mediocre [__] ass pieces
of [__] and I'm sorry I'm sorry I put up
with it so long so many years I had to
smile in your' face and be cool because
that's what we do to get our spots but
now I give no [__] about you especially
since I'm older now so [__] you
[__] like in the ass with a big
dick at I rapid Pace if you don't like
me I don't care like again I said I did
30 minutes the other night I ripped that
[__] and like I don't give a [__] who
you are oh I'm sorry you had to follow
me now after all those years I had to
follow you yeah I mean and then it's
almost like a lot of them are pissed off
that I made it and you go wait a minute
I did the work I can see if I [__] my
way up like a lot of [__] we
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah